wir werden noch mehr handel
wir können wir haben viel spielraum nach
oben wir haben auch über militär über
verteidigung gesprochen über selbst
viele verschiedene themen über
großartige dinge wir haben tolle
abschlüsse gefunden vielen dank danke
eingeladen
also ich wollte nur sagen ich kann das
bestätigen wir haben wir sehr positive
gespräche geführt dass der schüler
fortsetzen und ich glaube auch
angesichts der in beziehungen unserer
beiden länder zu ändern dann können wir
auch schwierige routen auf jeden fall
der ganze gipfel war toll
es war ein sehr produktiver g7-gipfel
wir kommen jetzt zu einem ende
heute nachmittag gibt es noch eine
pressekonferenz zumindest gebe ich eine
du vielleicht auch an geladen ich hoffe
doch wenn du eine machst dann komme ich
auf jeden fall zum zuschauen
wir werden dann nach der pressekonferenz
zurück in die usa aufbrechen
vielen dank wie sieht's denn mit den
zöllen auf deutsche autos aus ich hoffe
dass wir keine brauchen wir haben einige
lösungen gefunden über ein neues
handelsabkommen zwischen nicht nur
deutschland sondern auch zwischen den
usa und der eu gesprochen
ich denke wir haben hier gute
fortschritte gemacht ich hoffe dass wir
keine zelle brauchen können sie noch
etwas zu den wettkämpfen in syrien sagen
darüber haben wir vor ein paar minuten
gesprochen wir haben tausende von
kämpfern gefangen genommen
sie sind jetzt in unsere gefangenschaft
einen ganz verschiedenen orten aber vor
allem an einem sie kamen aus europa von
verschiedenen orten in europa und ich
hoffe dass europa die kämpfer
zurücknehmen wird
darüber haben wir auch gesprochen
in welchen phasen man die zurücknehmen
kann denn die usa haben hier wirklich
der den europäern einen großen dienst
erwiesen
100% des kalifats sein der besiegt
tausende von aes kämpfen haben wir
gefangen genommen einige von ihnen sind
hochgefährlich und wir denken sie
sollten in ihre herkunftsländer
zurückkehren
das wird passieren wir haben hier noch
keine abschließende lösung gefunden aber
es wäre unfair wenn die usa diese kämpfe
ist aufnehmen ist das sind ja nicht
unsere
damit haben sie und frau merkel über den
iran gesprochen hier eine lösung
gefunden
sie haben darüber nicht so viel
gesprochen aber natürlich ist die
atomfrage sehr wichtig wir werden hier
später noch ein g 7 statement dazu hören
wir dürfen nicht zulassen dass der iran
atomwaffen hat deutlich gemacht wir
wollen keine nukleare bewaffnung des
irans verhindert werden und wir wollen
das auf einen kann deswegen erreichen
und ich denke die gespräche waren sehr
produktiv um langsam weiter zu kommen
aber weil sie die klimafrage aus wir
haben hier große fortschritte gemacht
einerseits in bezug auf verschiedene
themen haben wir sehr viele eine
einigkeit gesehen
es gab viele fake news die gesagt haben
wir sehen uns nicht einig aber das
stimmt gar nicht wir sind total
harmonisch
alle sieben länder hier
es war ein wirklich tolles treffen und
der gefäß noch nicht vorbei wir haben
noch ein zwei treffen vor uns aber ich
verspreche ihnen wir hatten wirklich
viel einheit hier auch mit dem iran oder
in bezug auf den iran haben wir viel
fortschritt gemacht und haben mehr oder
weniger eine lösung gefunden zumindest
so weit wie man hier eine finden
es war ein sehr erfolgreicher g7-gipfel
sehr freundlich auch es gab auch einen
bericht als ich noch nicht mal mehr
gelandet bin
da hieß es schon dass ich mich hier
gestritten hatte wie soll ich mich denn
streiten wenn die noise gelandet bin
also da sieht man schon wie die
voreinstellungen sind quasi den usa geht
es gut
es gibt gute gespräche hochrangige
gespräche mit china es wurde von
bloomberg in anderen berichtet von
marketwatch dass ihr geld in den
chinesischen krandel wir wenn die
verhandlungen weil fawcett
glauben sie dass die eu und die usa und
hier dass der handel darf er ist ich
sage das mit respekt aber ich glaube die
eu ist für uns als land genauso
schwierig zum handeln wie china sie
haben uns nicht immer fair behandelt
über die jahre das kann natürlich auch
andersrum sein aber die eu ist ein
harter handelspartner
sie verhandeln die usa haben sehr viel
geld von der verloren im laufe der jahre
an die ehrung
das halte ich der eu nicht vor ich halte
es unsere regierung vor unseren
präsidenten die einfach keine gute
arbeit geleistet haben ich respektiere
die eu ich als bisher aus china man
schaut sich dann jemand wie joe biden an
der acht jahre lang zuletzt gemeinsam
mit obama dass china quasi uns auf den
füßen herum tritt ich mit china gemacht
habe hätte schon vor jahren passiert
passieren sollen
das war nicht nur präsident obama der
das verpasst hat auch viele von seinen
vorgängern hat milliarden euro dollar
pro jahr
sie klauen geistiges eigentum das sind
verlust in milliardenhöhe und das ist
einfach falsch
ich gebe hier nicht china die schuld
sondern unseren vertretern unserer
führung die einfach jemand nicht erfüllt
hat es ist den zahlen aus amerika auch
in vertiefte gespräche kommen und wir
haben ein großes interesse daran dass
unser handeln intensiviert ich glaube
wir können auch lesung in deutschland
setzt sich nicht im rahmen der ebene
sehr dabei
das klingt nicht gut